so the bannon and manafort pardons might
not actually shield those criminals
here's why manafort was convicted on
eight counts in virginia and two counts
in dc
but the jury hung on 10 different counts
and a prosecutor rarely charges all of
the possible crimes they can it would
confuse the jury but the thing is
the manafort pardon only pardons the
actual crimes that he was convicted of
so that means that a future prosecutor
might just simply charge the crimes that
they weren't able to get a conviction of
in the first place and the same goes for
bannon steve bannon's pardon only goes
towards offenses
actually charged and there's a whole
bunch of other fraud related charges
that the government could have brought
but hadn't at the time yet and the same
goes for roger stone george papadopoulos
alex vandenswan
and a whole bunch of the other
fraudsters that president trump pardoned
so if the biden administration has an
appetite they can go after almost all
these people and get almost the same
convictions just on slightly different
crimes
and heck a bunch of them actually
already pled guilty so it shouldn't even
be that complicated
but stay tuned and as always i'll see
you in court